a minha proposta de hoje eu vou começar
falando um pouquinho do meu histórico de
forma muito breve é alguns anos atrás eu
tive uma em uma experiência duradoura na
rede pública de ensino com professora de
antes e foi enriquecedor
eu trouxe uma imagem feita por uma aluna
que na época era uma adolescente né da
no colegial nome dela é que ela gomes e
essa foto é reveladora no que eu
vivenciei aqui eu ela consegue captar de
uma forma muito natural
a experiência que eu tive como o
professora porque o legal de ser
professor é você experimentar tanto você
tem experiência de exercitar sua
profissão e ao mesmo tempo se está uma
gênero generosidade de compartilhar o
que você conhece e isso não tem preço eu
vim de uma escola particular estudei
durante 11 anos numa escola privada
então foi um choque de realidade que é
realmente fez toda a diferença na minha
vida é aqui eu trago uma situação de
gabriel pvc que eu acho que ele define
muito bem a questão do ele faz uma ele é
um estudo sobre as palavras mas ele faz
uma reflexão em cima de onde vem a
palavra aluno né que é do a larry que a
questão de alimentação sustento do
crescimento
a educação que ele fala que é do cérebro
é que vem no verbete latim também que a
questão de trazer e aí acrescentam é
conduzir para fora então pensar no aluno
que você está criando alguém pra levar
pra fora e depois a parte da escola que
tinha uma conotação de espaço vital de
ócio de lazer que é muito diferente do
que a gente vencia hoje
e nesse contexto é mesmo gostando muito
da da parte da docência de lecionar
eu já tinha outro caminho que é a as
artes gráficas ea comunicação a minha
vida tomou outro rumo
por questões de
carreira reconhecimento eu tenho
questões financeiras e eu acabei
deixando a educação mas é algo que
sempre fica latente é até já vão fazer
dois anos no curso de gestão da
comunicação é a gente recebeu a proposta
de desenvolver um produto ou serviço
relacionado às mídias digitais
só que como eu disse como é muito
latente essa questão de educação porque
a educação é a base de uma de uma
sociedade que é um clique é um clichê
mas é real veio a questão é por que não
desenvolver algo pra educação e o que
nós profissionais de tecnologia
comunicação o qual é a nossa
contribuição porque os meus filhos vão
passar um dia por uma escola
nós passamos por uma escola o qual nossa
contribuição pra isso é pra sociedade
eu contei com meus colegas de vida e de
trabalho segundo spinelli e tales
carvalho que que apoiaram a ideia ea com
ele a coordenação liberou pra gente
fazer um trabalho de pesquisa não
desenvolveu o produto ea marca bem com
que o professor renato falou
aprendi direitinho a questão de antes de
a gente desenvolver um produto serviço
você precisa conhecer muito bem o seu o
seu cliente então de quem que a gente
está falando nesse contexto do aluno e
aquela experiência que ficou no passado
é que já faz muitos anos isso mudou
então a gente precisava ver como isso de
fato está acontecendo dentro da escola
então a gente procurou metodologia que
chama pesquisar são que ela prevê não
descarta tal que já foi pesquisado que
já foi visto até hoje os dados nem
estatísticas mas ela prevê
principalmente buscar informações foi
muito genuína direto dos agentes
então a gente foi atrás de desenvolver
questionários pegamos selecionamos faixa
etária de 6º e 9º ano é que a antiga 5ª
série 8ª série é questionar os próprios
professores e alunos entrevistas também
dirigidas por com o coordenador para vós
envolvemos termos de aceite e
autorização ea gente selecionou escolas
que fossem do setor municipal né
público municipal estadual e privado
a nossa ideia inicial era pegar escolas
que tivesse índices de de educação é que
fossem muito altos médios e e baixos só
que nessa busca das escolas conforme as
apresentações em esteve muito muito a
recusa é o que é ruim porque a nossa
idéia não era uma avaliação e uma
crítica ou levar isso adiante o previsor
não era ajudar a escola a ter esse olhar
como a tecnologia é dentro dela é com
que ela está funcionando a questão dos
professores e alunos e dá alguma solução
ou procura alguma melhoria ea gente teve
muita recusa então no final dessa
pesquisa né eu não levo no início a
gente conseguiu três escolas uma de cada
setor para desenvolver e os números eles
quando eles foram suficientes pra chegar
numa uma conclusão é passar um pouquinho
a gente selecionou escolas da região
campinas e região uma escola eu vou
passar muito breve pesquisa tá escola
municipal de monte mor
era uma zona rural conhecer uma zona
urbana com resquícios de rural e
predominantemente classe c
aqui vou tentar resumir é uma escola
super adaptada é foi muita surpresa pra
gente ver uma escola que está tão
desenvolvida tem 12 digital em todas as
salas dos professores foram capacitados
é teve sim lógico é a questão da
rejeição inicial por conta da da ponte
de gerações né da recusa mais teve
porque ele sim eles dele estavam com um
projeto de de começar com um sistema do
dom bosco que ele já prevê sem a
utilização de internet internet lousa
digital é então eles precisarão se
adaptar assim só que isso foi foi no
início mas a escola totalmente adaptada
inclusive com um sistema sala adaptada
pra alunos especiais com um computador
lado é bem interessante a escola a única
coisa que falta pela região eles têm
alguns problemas técnicos a parte de
monitor internet né monitora eu digo
alguém que fique lá disponível pra
auxiliamos mas é uma escola que
surpreendeu porque ela é pequena uma
zona que tinha acabado de passar por uma
transformação por isso tem resquícios
ainda é rurais mas subir é é a
tecnologia dentro da sua escola já está
muito avançada
a escola estadual aqui em campinas
urbana predominantemente classe b e c
também foi surpreendente a experiência
que eu tive na na escola era a
experiência de faltar outras coisas além
de tecnologia então essa escola além de
ter recursos tecnológicos mas o que a
gente conhece né como televisão rádios
tradicionais
eles têm uma sala de informática com 20
computadores mas ela é ociosa porque não
tem internet não tem também técnico não
tem manutenção mas a escola mesmo sem
isso eles conseguem ter um ótimo índice
do ideb que é um índice de educação
básica então você vê que mesmo não tendo
é o que o que a gente pensa nós uma sala
de informática fundamental nesse caso
ela não faz diferença no rendimento dos
alunos e pra para o desenvolvimento dos
professores dentro da sala de aula ea
outra sair outra escola é para uma
escola particular zona urbana
predominantemente classe a e b essa
escola particular ela tem todos os
recursos está numa região privilegiada é
a gente não conseguiu nessa pesquisa
fazer com os professores por falta de
disponibilidade de tempo não foi muito
difícil entrar na escola particular né
mas eles têm interessante nesse caso os
alunos eles não sentem tanta falta de
tecnologia porque eles já têm muitos
recursos em casa então mesma escola é é
tendo a possibilidade de comprar mais
recursos eles não exigem porque tem a 1
a única coisa que foi aberta neste caso
era a questão do tablet para diminuir o
volume na bolsa em durante o transporte
foi a única coisa eles não têm lousa
digital mais por uma questão de
curiosidade e interatividade e aqui
alguns depoimentos da visão dos alunos
né que aí a gente vê consegue até ver o
quanto os pais influenciam e os
professores também né então a questão
era se achava que a tecnologia ajudava
ou não dentro da sala de aula no
aprendizado deles então alguns colocaram
que sim que a tecnologia era legal
outro não porque não muda nada teve um
que não porque ela distrai provavelmente
a questão do videogame a mãe fala não
porque distrai não joga ea gente sabe
que os games ajudam sim o foco que mais
pra frente
aqui também tem um pouco mais outros
falam da complementação do das duas
coisas né eu livro didático vai ficar de
lado não é foi muito interessante que
avisam que a gente tem hoje dos nativos
digitais dos jovens que eles não se
interessam por algumas coisas mas isso
não é real pra mim foi surpreendente da
pesquisa porque ela trouxe alguns dados
como esse a criança não vai deixar de
ler de deter um livro se ela tiver um
recurso digital então muitos apareceu
essa coisa da com dicas e complementar
mesmo recurso do com outro né
aqui a gente tem algumas referências de
escolas que a gente pesquisou escolas
que têm é tecnologia tanto fora como
dentro do país não é só a questão da
tecnologia é toda uma reestruturação
física do espaço do comportamento dos
professores à rai tec rai que é uma rede
de escola américa e da americana da
califórnia ela tem escolas para os
alunos de dados irregulares também pós
graduação dos professores
ela tem toda uma reestruturação física e
será legal fica como referência a nave
né que fica no recife e urgente que é o
ginásio de experimentar novas
tecnologias que fiz
na no rio de janeiro na favela da
rocinha é muito legal vale a pena dar
uma pesquisada não vou me aprofundar tá
o recado que eu tenho que dar para os é
assim eu tentei separar porque é é a
gente buscou por conta da pesquisa dá um
foco nas escolas que tinham tecnologia
tá tecnologia todos os tipos de recursos
sejam os mais tradicionais como uma
televisão que seja até uma sala de
informática totalmente adaptado ea gente
chegou a algumas conclusões
é a principal delas que eu coloco aqui
os diretores
ele é fundamental para a história a
minha metáfora que é que eu fiz é que o
diretor seria o cozinheiro os
professores seriam os ingredientes é eu
já passei por escolas que tinha muito
professor bom mas que o prodígio setor
acaba acordando ea escola continuava na
mesma
é interessante que o renato colocou
porque é isso mesmo da mesma forma a
questão do marketing
hoje o que acontece nas escolas é algo
que é antigo e não repensado
não se olha o novo perfil do aluno não
se pense em novas estratégias também de
educação e isso faz muito diferentes e o
diretor
se ele tiver os ingredientes bons e
realmente soube cozinhar
ele vai fazer o melhor prato se tiver
dois ovos que significa professores não
tão bons e ele foi bom ele vai conseguir
ainda fazer ter algum resultado
agora também os ingredientes fazem todas
diferentes então eu tentei criar essa
metáfora para falar da importância do
diretor que ele precisa saber escutar a
escola tive caso de um de diretores é
achar que a escola dele e isso é muito
grave porque por mais que a escola seja
privada ela construída o que acontece a
gente tem uma nivelação hoje do ensino
de você querer colocar num estado o
mesmo tipo de escola mas cada escola
está inserida num lugar diferente então
você não consegue vê-la na mesma cidade
você tem escolas de periferia escolas
centrais com perfis completamente
diferentes
então para o diretor que seria o
principal a cabeça disso ele precisa
rever dentro daquele contexto que ele
faz parte o qual seria a melhor forma
forma disso a questão dos professores é
muito importante eu já escutei pessoas
fazem querendo fazer pedagogia falando
que gosta de criança não é o suficiente
é só o primeiro passo é gostar de
criança ou adolescente
mas não é porque o professor é ele
precisa ser muito valorizado porque ele
tem que ter um entendimento muito grande
de várias áreas sobre psicologia
pedagogia eu coloquei neurociências
porque esse entendimento do
funcionamento do cérebro eu li um livro
que vou passar a referência pra você e
educação e neurociência que ela fala
isso como qq um professor é vai dar
aulas sem cabeça e funcionamento físico
e biológico dentro da cabeça do seu
aluno isso é importantíssimo que na
neurociência lá atrás é ela é na verdade
ela vai se aliar ao professor porque
você consegue criar novas estratégias
para atingir aquele aluno se você souber
um pouquinho de neurociência você talvez
entenda ou crie alguma forma de atender
melhor o aluno que tem dislexia por
exemplo então é muito interessante vale
a pena quem a professora eu indico a
leitura muito bom e o professor ele tem
que se capacitar
o que acontece por conta dessa distância
de gerações
ele tem que ter esse respeito de a
escola ou é quem ensina é quem quem
espera que o professor se capacite tem
que dar esse tempo porque o que acontece
é a experiência que eu tive o professor
era ele ou ele vai capacitar e deixe de
dar aula naquele horário só que aquilo
vai implicar no final do mês
ou ele não se capacita então isso
precisa
ser respeitado é ter chorar professor
fazer essa capacitação
independente isso ele tem que estar
muito tranqüilo pra que não impacta no
salário dele do final do mês
isso é muito importante eo professor ele
precisa ter empatia porque se você não
não olha a realidade do seu aluno é
muito comum professor falar que ela não
vá a conselho e outras coisas mas por
trás daquilo tudo complicado de ser
professor é isso é porque você lida com
indivíduos pessoas completamente
diferentes
então você tem que entender o que
acontece às vezes aquele aluno ele não
comeu em casa então você precisa ter a
consciência de que aquele comportamento
dele é uma é um reflexo de alguma coisa
é muito complexo deixei rapidinho e para
os pais o primeiro alerta que eu dou já
existem pesquisas eu indico que busquem
crianças menores de 2 anos não bem
tablet não tem celular é porque
atrapalha o desenvolvimento cognitivo
crianças precisam brincar
existe um documentário que chama terra
branca excelente assistam para quem
inspira em vocês então pais depois os
dois anos de forma moderada a questão
que coloco o monitoramento tem que ser
de forma não invasiva porque você tem
que respeitar a individualidade do filho
é criar hábitos também é muito
importante hábito hábito de leitura um
hábito de estudo
aqui eu retomo a fala do gabriel né
porque a educação é isso na verdade é
você precisa rever a escola como um todo
criar e se esse hábito todo a reforma do
posto mas rapidinho quando o horário
a reforma na escola que tem que ser
revista tanto a questão estrutural de
monitoramento a gente precisa criar
alunos que sejam mais conscientes que
não entrei na internet na rede e falem
porque acham então a gente precisa criar
é realmente cidadão mais crítico com uma
consciência que saiba buscar que sabe
atrás da informação
aqui é uma reflexão da martha gabriel
não é que eu acho que resume isso
necessário imprescindível é uma questão
de bom senso
você vê aquela realidade e você mudar
aquilo de acordo com aquela realidade
então é reflexão em bonn sente e aqui o
para os professores né que resumindo os
professores se tornam imortais ele aos
passar dos anos ele deixa aquele legado
para os seus alunos
é isso agradeço algumas referências
brigada